Haylee bieber is setting the record
straight yeah that's me
fans have been coming out the model for
her wait for it pinky fingers yep
the Bieber stepped out for their first
red carpet as a married couple on Monday
they packed on the PDA while attending
the premiere for Justin's YouTube
docu-series but fans were seemingly more
focused on her pinkies now hailey is
asking fans to stop roasting her for it
the 23 year old showed off her left
pinky on Instagram saying I've made fun
of myself about this for forever so I
might as well tell everyone else why
they're so crooked and scary in a second
post that has since been deleted Halley
reportedly shared the Wikipedia page for
the condition ectrodactyly writing it
causes my pinky fingers to look the way
they do
its genetic I've had it my whole life so
people can stop asking me wTF is wrong
with their pinky fingers here is what's
wrong lol she topped it off with a
message for her followers saying
so in conclusion please stop roasting me
about my pinky fingers who I am
take it or leave it but we can always
count on her hubby's to show her some
love he's just really sweet he's a good
kid a good heart and I love him
Justin stopped by The Ellen Show earlier
this week and here's what he had to say
about his wifey she's an amazing of may
amazing person yeah she seems like it
she really is she's super precious yeah
I enjoy spending my life with her
[Music]